hey guys how's it goin so today I have
been taking some photos and video burkas
and today so she has a photographer
coming later but we're like okay we need
to have some people for you getting
ready and all this stuff so that's what
I've been doing
she looks so pretty I've known Kristen I
think since she was like fours we can
put out the lights together we can go we
can go up straighten yours and
everything is so hey say
it is just you and I and everything is
so thing is so so call me out call me
out baby baby we can go
anything you want to say to Kristen on
her wedding day is your Christian a
happy wedding day I am so happy to be
here and I'm also happy that Justine
wanted to come to Germany with me we
love you and I don't know let's go get
you married
Oh Kristen I would like to say to you
like congratulations I'm so excited I
remember watching you play softball when
you were like four and you and Jenna
used to torment me when you guys were
little and now you are getting married I
might cry I don't cry
I'm embarrassed stop you're one of a
kind
nobody's breaking your spirit you're
looking sapphire
nobody's breaking you're breaking your
you're keeping up recep's our tape so we
just dance alone every dance like no
one's watching
Kristen is officially married and now
it's time to cut the log clearly if you
guys haven't noticed this is a German
wedding so there's a bunch of traditions
that I'm not familiar with and cutting
the log is one of them I'm excited about
this I'm gonna film it
together we can
kill me
my wedding video here in Germany I had
such a great time so congratulations
Kristen and Leto
thank you so much for the invite I
filmed a lot more for a video that I
made for them but I didn't actually put
it all in this video because I felt like
it's their wedding and I don't have to
hold it all on YouTube but either way I
hope you guys enjoyed the video I had a
great time in Germany and now we're off
to another destination I might already
be in that destination or I might not be
we still don't really know where we're
going on this trip but they doing for
more fun adventures see you then
waiting but you get on the boat or you
missed